de simples bâtonnets de la colle et des
feutres à deux ans et demi c'est déjà
tout un univers et des techniques à
découvrir
monia est venu spécialement ici pour
partager un moment avec son fils c'est
bien pour lui pour moi ça permet de
développer beaucoup de choses chez
l'enfant un moment
de partage parce que des rencontres
aussi deux enfants et puis non en route
les professionnelles et professionnels
de l'enfance partager autrement c'est le
thème de cette cinquième édition de la
fête de la petite enfance à trappes
une journée d'échangés entre parents
enfants et professionnels où le jeu est
mis à l'honneur le jeu vos parties de
l'éveil de l'enfant il est très
important de partager ce moment avec eux
on a une vie qui s'accélère de plus en
plus et là ça on a de moins en moins de
temps pour les petits bouts tout donc
c'est un moment qu'on apprend à partager
avec son enfant il y a
ago le relaxation où on apprend à
partager avec son bébé sans l'enfant
plus grand des moments de détente ceux
qui sont très importants avec un ballon
petite balle molle souple ou une petite
voiture justement en faisant des
mouvements tout doucement sans remonter
en descendant fait pour détendre la
personne
la ville compte une vingtaine
d'assistantes maternelles publiques avec
ce type d'événement elle espère
sensibiliser les parents mais aussi les
futurs parents de la commune